hello everyone we're super excited to be
here with you today this is my hour this
is our first time at strange loop after
being long time fans uh and we're
delighted to see so many faces that I'm
sure I would recognize if I saw your
avatar
uh we want to let you know that slides
and speaker notes are both available at
bit.ly
backslash breaking Dash the dash
internet
so hello
um welcome to remember when we broke the
internet
so you may be here to listen to us tell
stories about when we were personally
responsible for breaking the internet
um but we are not going to tell those
horror stories today
so
um what we are going to do is take a
look at the times when open source or
something that looks very much like it
cause disruption in our technological
landscape
and that's not nearly as straightforward
as our post-mortems and our
retrospectives would have us believe
because it's
all interconnected
we'll be diving into the complex
socio-technical systems
and to see how they intersect with open
source
so you're not going to see a single line
of code I'm sorry
um but what you will see might amuse you
or humiliate us
we're not really sure
it's going to be great
so I'm Julia
um I have been working in open source
for most of my career
um and I call myself an open source
archaeologist because I dig into
projects into data and I try to figure
out what is going on in the system
at a large scale
where are the series of tiny Walls
series of small walls and I'm Amanda
casseri I'm fortunate that most recently
my work has focused on understanding the
nuances of Open Source where it works
where it needs support and where all the
things tucked away in the back room that
we didn't know were holding up the
internet
so now before we jump into Story Time
Julia and I would like to level set with
you a few foundational Concepts to make
sure we're all on the same page
this is the obligatory what is open
source slide who here uses open source
excellent
um who here knows the definition of Open
Source
yeah so there are certain criteria that
open source or project has to fulfill in
order to be considered technically open
source
so
these were laid out in 1998 when the
open source definition was created
and
we're just going to spend a tiny bit of
time going through it this is the driest
part of the talk I promise
so in order to be open source
you got to have the code it's got to be
available modifiable and redistributable
those are the ones that most people know
also though it has to be technology
neutral and it has to respect the
authors
integrity and intent
open source does not mean that you don't
have intellectual property rights
also you are obligated to distribute the
license of any open source software that
you use I am contractually obligated to
say this anytime I'm on stage
there are asterisks to that that don't
really apply to this talk
finally there are things you can't do
if you're still going to be considered
open source you can't discriminate
against people groups or areas of use
that means you cannot prevent an
industry that you do not like
from using your technology
it also can't restrict the use of other
software so project a can't prevent you
from using Project B
and I also can't restrict the type of
project or product that you use it for
that's the dry part
and it's done right we I will say Julie
and I do use open source sometimes as a
term and a concept and lots of different
things and so we wanted to make sure we
were setting really here like when
you're talking about open source
licensure as it applies towards our talk
and history
this is the framework we will be talking
about open source within and it will
come up again welcome back
come up but not like that
um
can you step one step that way I'm sorry
working on mics this is the first time
we've done a talk in person together and
we've worked together since 2019 so this
is super exciting
yeah thanks for the clap totally totally
appreciate it
helps
self on a blank screen over any other
platform so I love that everybody's here
thank you
um and so okay first we're going to have
a very brief introduction into
complexity Theory this is complexity
Theory 101 an entire semester in one
slide the conceptual framework of
complexity theory is that this defines
complex systems so complexity theory
states I keep getting feedback
do my best if anybody has any
suggestions you can shout them out
complexity theory states that while
complex systems are unpredictable they
are constrained by order generating
rules so a complex system has components
that interact
in multiple ways
following local rules and there is no
unifying rule that defines all
interactions as much as scientists would
really like that to happen also in a
complex system the emergent system is
greater than the sum of its parts
next we have a special kind of complex
system a socio-technical one
some of those shapes are now people
in a socio-technical system we have two
new considerations
you cannot separate out the social
and Technical aspects of an organization
because they are linked
inextricably
as much as we like to pretend otherwise
sometimes
we also need to ensure that we account
for the interactions between our
society's complex structures
and the behaviors of the people who live
within them hi
I'm one of those people
but what does that have to do with open
source
well when we examine the evolution and
individual layers of Open Source we can
see that open source has components that
interact in multiple ways following
local rules there is no unifying rule to
Define all interactions in open source
and that margin system is greater than
the sum of its parts so I think we can
confidently say that open source is a
complex system
and
physiological conclusion here is that it
is also a socio-technical system if we
want to understand open source and how
it changes we have to acknowledge the
open source is fundamentally about
people and Technology
we cannot remove how we as humans
interact with
ourselves
each other
and the different technical components
of our systems without reducing the
problem
to the point of meaninglessness
this is the this is most important when
disruptions happen which fundamentally
change the landscape of Open Source
so if we want to talk about disruptions
and ecosystems some of these may be what
are called a Black Swan event and so
what makes these events so special there
are three critical components that must
exist for us to consider A disruption a
Black Swan event so Black Swan events
ultimately disrupt the status quo that
cause systemic change and they seem
inevitable in hindsight So today we're
going to focus with you on a few
specific events in the history of Open
Source which highlight the complex
socio-technical nature of our evolving
ecosystem
so
in order to explain specific Black Swan
events
we have to look at them in their
historical context
any amateur historians here
okay we're gonna make amateur historians
of all of you
for anyone who's worked in open source
for more than like a couple weeks
you have this idea of how it used to be
looking back farther
as we do in open source science and
Archeology we distinctly see where open
source has evolved over time
as well as where Evolution happens
through the disruption of norms
So speaking of disruption of norms uh we
we've talked about this before Julia in
a timeline and I know you have a great
project an open source project that
looks at the timeline of Open Source but
I think for today for this audience and
the World At Large if we want to get
everyone to understand how big of a
disruption this is I think we should try
maybe something different than just a
timeline
maybe what do you support you propose
how about a song
is that a cat playing a piano it is
that sounds really cheesy and I'm I'm a
Cheesy person so let's do it okay
fantastic so we we are gonna sing the
lyrics and if sing and if you are
familiar with the chorus of this
specific song that is being parodied
then we would love for you to sing along
we will provide the lyrics for the
chorus uh and we hope that you just do
your best maybe help us about and we'll
all get there together just like in open
source but we're also perfectly happy
looking foolish on stage alone oh yeah
it'll just be awkward for everyone but
singing loudly and audience
participation is highly encouraged and
appreciated
oh
ready okay
all right
and titcathera mathematicians Ada
Loveless difference engines world wars
Alan Turing Grace Hopper d bugs public
domain arpanet now we can all typeset
software copyright like a book not a
light
new guy comes on the scene MIT license
Macintosh Commodores free softwares On
The Run Morris worms licensing GP l or
BSD Linux python combat boots for
everyone okay pause pause here okay
we're gonna go back rewind be kind we're
gonna go back to 1988. so in 1988 there
were about 60 000 computers networked
together to form the public internet and
so while there was an increasing number
of Industry networks all selling the
power of connection in the workplace a
majority of these computers were
government or academic systems and the
Morris worm or the worm because it was
so famous was created inadvertently
asterisk this asterisk indicates a point
that is a little contentious but we all
agree on to be congenial people so
Within inadvertently released by Robert
taplin Morris and Morris was a student
at Cornell but released the worm via a
system at MIT in order to prevent it
being traced back to him as a part of a
research project examining internet
systems and how their open protocols
could be exploited
this worked much quicker than Morris
expected and by exploiting multiple
operating system vulnerabilities most
importantly by exploiting the transitive
trust that existed at the time between
sysadmins and users the Morris were
infected about 10 percent of the global
internet in a matter of days
so there are many notable firsts from
this event which include being the first
computer worm to be distributed via the
Internet as opposed to traded on floppy
disks or removable media Morris was also
the first felony conviction in the U.S
under the 1986 Computer Fraud and Abuse
Act I feel like we can all relate here
right
right it's just a project I swear
okay so so why does this event matter to
open source and how is it a Black Swan
event right so using our magical glasses
of hindsight we can clearly see where
the status quo was changed and how this
influences how we operate still today so
first of all we do not assume that
everyone is operating and everyone
else's best interest this event happened
in November of 1988 and that was months
before GPL and Linux were released for
the first time so we cannot ignore the
human interests Community expectations
and social trust that existed at the
time of those releases all of which were
fundamentally impacted by the Morris
worm the reaction to and recovery from
the Morris worm also demonstrated the
robustness of an Internet which is
designed as a partionable distributed
system which prioritized open knowledge
sharing so Morris quickly worked to move
fixes to the worm onto multiple to pull
mailing lists and CIS admins were able
to work together to isolate damage and
prevent impacted systems from infecting
farther
so because of the Morris worm the
internet and the software which runs on
it which it runs on is totally changed
there's a pivot in security regulation
and international laws we didn't want
all systems to look alike anymore before
super homogeneity was seen as an
efficiency now it's seen as a risk and
also there was a hard lean at the time
especially in industry and government to
move to proprietary systems
now back to the song
time for the chorus this is the audience
participation part so everyone who knows
this please join in
We Didn't Start the Fire
it was always burning since the world's
been turning We Didn't Start the Fire no
we didn't light it but we tried to fight
it
JavaScript Ruby Murphy versus Libby open
source gets a name cves ain't cheap ASF
and an l f p s f so many F's
time
TCP dump Trojan gets released for Keeps
canoe guy drives a way more women every
day
everyone's got a bug
[Applause]
everyone's got a bug maintainership is
now a slug dive into vaporize codes of
conduct On The Rise underpaid
unmaintained openness is a slow
compromise that was a stretch but it
works we promise we promise okay so so
wait wait we need to stop at 2014.
this is one of my favorite examples
when talking about open source is a
complex
socio-technical ecosystem
so heart bleed
was first released like it was a product
launch
um in in 2012
but it was only publicly disclosed two
years later in 2014.
so what was it
well it was a an issue with one of the
most popular open source cryptography
libraries called openssl
it made user entered data vulnerable to
being captured by
doctors malicious and non-malicious
alike though we don't talk about the
non-malicious ones right right right
right okay
so with that data
malicious actors could impersonate users
compromising
more information
it affected because of the composition
of the internet at the time at a minimum
of 66 percent of the internet
including
government databases
they don't hold any sensitive
information right
no
okay
so this really Drew attention to the
fact that while open source itself
is a distributed system
maintainership isn't necessarily
very few people at the time realized
that openness a cell
in 2014 2012 to 2014 was maintained by
effectively one person
some Reports say too
but effectively one
and it was maintained on an entirely
volunteer basis
the maintainer had a day job
they didn't have time
to go and Patch this critical piece of
Open Source software insert XKCD comic
here
an argument in favor of Open Source is
that many eyes make all bugs shallow
but if somebody doesn't have time
to incorporate a fix
we've got an issue
so in openssl's case the maintainer
didn't have time
given their job to mitigate heartblade
this resulted in companies
trying to throw money at the problem
and essentially paid the maintainer to
take a leave from their job
and fix heart bleed
so increased interest and focus on open
source sustainability
supply chain analysis
something we hear sometimes every once
in a while these days right just a
little just a little
um and how
to go about trying to find these
dependencies
that you know hold up the internet
and more companies that relied on open
source all of them
um
Found A Renewed reason to invest in open
source whether that was through funding
through sponsored development
what have you because they saw it as an
investment in their own stability
it's not entirely altruistic it's
for their own good too
so
openssl but back to the song
chorus
okay time for another chorus so please
again that was a great effort let's be a
little even louder and everybody join in
honestly surprised yeah
We Didn't Start the Fire
it was always burning since the world's
been turning We Didn't Start the Fire
no we didn't light it but we tried to
fight it transitive dependencies gnarly
graphs not clean trees
oops
naming things is tricky left pad not in
registry
okay uh this is getting more frequent
Now isn't it I mean we could
success of Open Source but yeah it's
kind of happening a lot more now yeah
yeah so okay so it's now 2016.
uh to those of you not familiar left pad
is the name of a package in the npm
registry this is the node.js package
management uh which is also commonly how
this event is referred to
um so in in 2016 there was a trademark
disagreement over an npn package name
specifically not leftpad itself but a
different package and when that
trademark disagreement was filed with
the registry which was then and now
Still Remains privately held
um npm sided with the trademark holder
over the developer who had named their
package that name so in response the
maintainer deleted all of his npm
packages including leftpad and it was
this deletion left bad from the package
registry that showed how deep of a
transitive dependency left pad had
become for many other packages in the
npm ecosystem and because of the way npm
references dependencies during their
build process this caused widespread
failure including crashing many popular
websites and services
can I interrupt you for a second sure
yeah yeah can you remind
me it it puts spaces to the left
oh okay it formats you know like
I I think using a package to put spaces
to the left could have could have
potentially been seen as a yeah yeah I
think I think that's a good thing to
examine formatting um transitive
dependencies though very challenging
thing people want to reuse code code's
supposed to be reusable that's a tenant
we have right this this this is not
simple Julia it's complex
okay so in response npm restorative
version of the unpublished package
without the maintainer's consent
okay oh I hear a lot of ooze in the
audience okay
I do have to bring
to bring that we do have to say uh
unpublishing code and releases was
perfectly legal remains perfectly legal
remains perfectly legal under the open
source licensure terms as well as terms
and conditions of the privately owned
package manager so we've heard of the
phrase
free to Fork which refers that's that's
a big F capital F Fork by the way not
like the git command which refers to the
fact that licenses outline shareability
or not reusability or not an attribution
or not choose your license carefully so
this also puts a bright Spotlight on the
node.js development philosophy which at
the time uh had a decreased awareness in
dependency complexity for developers as
they were choosing how to build things
so as you pointed out uh well at the
time it was quite popular to use other
people's things and connect things
together regardless of the dependency
tree that you were building
um and so as a result we yet again get a
glimpse just like before into the
increasing costs of maintainer burnout
or losing one maintainer from an
ecosystem as well as kicking off a new
round of discussions around maintainer
rights and open source contractualism
uh there was also additional scrutiny
placed around privately run package
managers for open source software which
remains a contested discussion now with
again the current emphasis placed on
securing the software supply chain
um and we were on a roll before that
rude Interruption so we're going to get
back to it deep breath let's go back to
the song Julia this one's yours
what was once Community now has become a
strategy driving towards the stock
exchange now yet another license change
okay pause again
pause again sorry we have to stop again
oh this is me okay well
now we get into some of the more
controversial territory of this talk
it's time for everyone's favorite
technical Topic in open source
the legal side it's not as dry as the
beginning though we promise this is much
more and also we are not lawyer cats
we're not lawyers just as our disclosure
for that part too I really an amazing
amount of Regulation though I know but
we have to say you don't have the ears
okay
so
as I mentioned before we've done an
amazing job at convincing people of the
value of Open Source
good job us
yeah awesome yeah but we might have
swung the pendulum a little too far
Maybe
because
open source once was an expression of
freedom of Counter Culture and a little
bit of subversion but not the source
control system
um and it's now a part of
a business model
companies developed open source software
with the goal of monetizing it
additionally it was around the same time
that this thing called the cloud
offered companies
a way to not have to be in the business
of data centers
it gave them the flexibility
and the ability to focus on their core
product differentiation their business
instead of optimization
use cloud service providers saw the
opportunity to take this further by
offering managed services
namely running open source projects for
you
this effectively cut out the companies
who had developed the open source
Technologies
out of the equation and made it so that
they couldn't realize on their
anticipated monetization
so they explored other options and in
some cases they switched away
from open source models all together
that was a very
large oversimplification of a lot of
years
I have personal opinions on this matter
which are not uncontroversial
but the long and short of it is
the cloud providers were actually
perfectly within the rights to do what
they did
it's entirely allowed under the open
source model
were they monetizing open source yes
had others done this before them
yeah
what had shifted was our technological
landscape
because we have been we're focusing on
developer productivity instead of end
user products
and this had a tremendous amount of
impact on open source itself
we saw and are still seeing a muddying
of the open source Waters
you're hearing the phrases open core or
Source available as companies try to
keep their reputations as open source
companies without actually being open
source
and we have seen those public capital F
Forks
that attempt to keep the project going
as it had been prior to the license
change
and in some cases that's bifurcated the
development community
and it's introduced a little bit of
confusion in the overall ecosystem
there's an increasing amount of
discussion around how companies can
participate in the open source ecosystem
and be additive to it
but
sometimes even more importantly in the
ecosystems View
um
in the ecosystems view is how companies
can participate in open source and be
seen to do so and be measured to do so
um oh and there's this thing called
capitalism I don't know if you've heard
of it
it put an increased pressure increased
amount of conversation about how
capitalism intersects with open source
or doesn't and that is something that
still has not even hashed
and probably I I don't think any of us
will see it hashed out actually no no
one unifying rule yeah
so
um you know the drill
one more time this is the final course
everybody so give it all you got ready
okay
We Didn't Start the Fire
it was always burning since the world's
been turning We Didn't Start the Fire
but when we are gone it will still burn
on and on and on and on and on and on
and on and on she's got more staying
no training no training
okay
so just like the song we could go on and
on and on and on and on mostly because
we keep getting new material to add to
this deck yeah we stopped at 2018
there's way more to go
um you may have noticed some notable
exceptions that may be more recent
um
but there are fundamental challenges
which exist in a larger open source
ecosystem which are accelerating these
Black Swan events
yeah and we I think to close out today
would like to offer you a few
mitigations uh which could fundamentally
shift us these are the ones we recommend
as well as ones we try to do but shift
us all towards a new future
so part of the open source ethos is
transparency
but
interestingly enough
it's primarily been directed at the code
and there's so much more to open source
than the code it is a socio-technical
system
the rest of how open source operates is
oftentimes lost
to walled Gardens
private conversations
at an over indexing
on Source control as the only source of
truth that matters
we need to bring transparency more into
open source
bring it into the aspects of Open Source
that are currently still in the dark
we have to explore
ways that open source needs to evolve
in order to reduce the frequency of
these box one events
transparency is no longer a core tenet
of open sourced
but it should be
so glue work is the phrase created by
Tanya Riley to describe the work that
can mean the difference between a
project that succeeds and one that fails
and when we talk about maintenance and
sustainability there remains a focus on
certain forms of contributions but even
within the binary categorization which I
despise of code versus non-code work
Feature work and advancing new versions
of a package are given more visibility
than any of the engineering glue work
which enables our entire ecosystem
glue work is not as visible as the
critical essential work of Open Source
but it should be
so I'm going to talk yet again about
something that no one wants to talk
about
the history of Open Source like most
histories
art is largely told from one perspective
and that hampers our ability to both
reason about how events have come to
pass
as well as it influences technology
decisions in the future
open source
has a cult of personality problem
that is a reaction I was not expecting
one second well I internalized that
um The Cult of Personality problem
contributes
to the problems in sustainability
reliability
and overall longevity of the open source
ecosystem
we need to shine lights on these missing
or Untold narratives including the glue
work
that makes open source possible
this may seem at odds with calling out
the cult of personality problem but
they're actually just two sides to the
same coin
an imbalance in celebrating these Untold
narratives leaves to some leads to some
work being undervalued
and celebrate and celebrating the
um
kind of credit hungry flashy work
in open source
it's a sustainability
reliability and Longevity problem
narratives are not complete but they
should be
so we didn't light this fire
but
we're staying to fight it and
really hope that you do too
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
that was like literally the most nervous
I've ever been yeah that was terrifying
absolutely terrifying thanks so much for
and are singing along
uh we did want to leave you with a list
of references because uh we can't help
but be ourselves and we have to have
references and referrals
um we will uh we will hang out it's
break now I think everybody can can
break we're gonna hang out for questions
so if you'd like to talk to us or ask
anything if you have a comment that's
not a question maybe listen but uh what
happy to sit around and talk with y'all
or find you later uh in the conference
so thank you so much for coming
[Applause]